companies have a tendency to look
inwards during recessions you're you
know you've got a million efficiency
efforts going on largely cost driven and
I think it's the worst mistake companies
can make so what I'm doing is try to
number one lead by example I spend a lot
of time out with all of our customers
because fundamentally I find their
businesses really interesting and I
don't kid myself to believe that I'm
doing proper customer research but it's
important for me businesses come alive
for me when I'm out with the customers
when I see how they interact with
products and services we provide and
when when I'm with the frontline staffs
all around the world within thomson
reuters what I'm trying to do internally
is to streamline as much as possible all
of the worthy internal projects that are
there you know I'm constantly asking the
question if there's a meeting and people
are sending out a 50-page slide pack why
not a 10-page why why do you need it at
all if there's pre-reading and there are
three articles that would be brilliant
for some off-site how about just one and
the knock-on effect in a big company of
de layering and having everybody ask the
question you know can I make this as
simple as possible but no simpler to
steal a favorite Einstein line I think
that's especially powerful when you're
going through a difficult period and
your customers really need you and need
your help
you